bonjour moi j'appelle eric j'ai 35 ans
et je suis auteur compositeur pour les
chants de supporters de foot oui par
exemple ce matelas chanson là haut et
oui bon ça c'est moi qui les ai écrites
là ils sont soixante mille 2 euros par
personne il est enchanté trois fois
bîmes 360 mille euros et le match a même
pas commencé
cinq mois j'ai écrit les plus grands
titres on t'encule
ça c'est moi ou alors on bat [ __ ] ta
mère
ça c'est moi aussi c'est le plus dur
c'est pas de proposer c'est d'écrire
cela n'a été achevée parce qu'ils sont
trop sale avec le cateau dans lesdites
un par un ce nul
nommé meilleur titre c'est paris paris
on t'encule au départ moi j'avais écrit
paris paris on embête
allez-y par exemple fait le paris paris
on tempête
c'est vrai qu'il est pas le sait ça
exactement en fait y'a pas il ya ce côté
un peu sympa du arrête et qu'on michel
entend vais t'acheter mines bousculade
alors que paris on t'encule
on voit tout de suite l'idée principale
du truc et c'est paris on t'encule pas
je t'encule donc on est plusieurs
imaginé plusieurs personnes sont dans
vos fesses c'est pas agréable
voyez d'accord 3 4 elles sont où tes
jambes tes jambes manque un truc on
refait elles sont où tes jambes des
jambes fils de [ __ ]
voilà c'est ça gwendal fils de [ __ ]
voyez on vient de faire une belle tarte
aux pommes et gwendal a rajouté la
chantilly
pascal obispo lui utilise beaucoup le
mot amour dans ses chansons christophe
maé elle utilise plus le mode moi c'est
plus basé un petit peu autour de well
and us
en cuir
ok je crois qu'on est nourri single est
finalement qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
niveau de la ligue 1 la ligue 1 oui je
connais pas la tête
ok
[ __ ]
ambühl
cela tannant culé